usually on set we got a huge red camera
it's on like a ronin stabilizer we're
going around getting cinematic shots
like this but what if i told you you
could do all that with just your cell
phone
find out how
cinematic shots or cinematic stuff in
general is basically dehumanizing your
footage you start breaking through to a
different type of reality something that
is uh not in our world the things you
got to keep in mind when getting
cinematic is your composition your
dynamic range your lighting your
movement your sound oddly enough and
then of course what kind of color
grading you're going to put on the
footage after the fact how to take cool
shots with your cell phone tip one
so what is dynamic range we may have
talked about this before but we're going
to touch upon it right now it's
basically it's uh how bright the
brightest part in your scene is and how
dark the darkest part in the scene is is
the range of light your sensor can
capture between where it's just noise
and it can't tell the difference between
light and pure black noise
and pure clipped out white because your
sensor on the camera are these little
cells that when light hits in the emit
voltage and at a certain point so much
light can hit these little cells that
they top out and they're just maxed out
voltage saying yeah i'm getting all the
light i can get
and then you know there's no more beyond
that going up and the same thing going
down where at a certain point just the
random noise of the universe is matching
those few rare photons that are hitting
the sensor and the sensor can't
differentiate between what's actual
signal and what's just noise aka signal
to noise ratio we have the sky up there
as you can tell it's pretty bright but
let's say looking underneath this chair
here
this shadow here is kind of very dark so
what it's basically that range of
brightness to darkness if you think
about an oil painting artists are
sitting there and they're painting
everything and the lights are usually
rich in color and the shadows usually
have all this detail on them that's
because paint is effectively a infinite
dynamic range canvas so when you're
getting a picture and you have that full
dynamic range and you have rich detail
on the shadows and you even still get
detail in the sky and the clouds
that's when things start to look very
painterly when things start to look
painterly they start to look cinematic
the camera that we're shooting on right
here this is the the red and it's got
the dragon sensor which can capture an
enormous amount of dynamic range the sun
could be shining in the sky you can
still see the shadows underneath there
however when using a cell phone and as i
expose for the sky to the point we can
actually see detail on the clouds
you lose out in the alleyway it just
turns black when i expose for the
alleyway so that the sensor's letting in
enough light it's letting in so much
light that the sky is completely
overloading the sensor cell phones don't
have good dynamic range
what can you do about it tips for
maximizing your dynamic range on the
phone don't shoot against a bright
background right now i'm getting a
selfie shot of me against the sky my
face is exposed but the sky is all
clipped here's my shot exposed to the
sky
my face which is now just basically pure
shadow so try to avoid shooting in front
of things like windows a person against
the sky unless you're specifically going
for a silhouette look so avoid those
high dynamic range situations tip number
two use a reflector or a silk to
minimize the dynamic range or your scene
take for example the shot of me
against the sky i'm gonna hold this
reflector right here which is now
reflecting the sky and brings the
brightness of my face up so now if i
expose my face
the brightness of my face is closer to
that of the sky so the phone doesn't
have to capture as large of a range of
light but what is a silk the silk is
basically a thin white piece of fabric
that if it was a sunny day out you could
hold it up and it puts me in a shadow
but it's a very diffused shadow that
doesn't completely cut the sun and more
softens the light around me so here's my
next tip favor your highlights rather
than your shadows here's what i mean by
that if your phone has manual exposure
set it for the scene and then darken the
scene just a touch so what you're doing
when you lower the exposure in the scene
just a little bit is you're taking those
highlights that might be clipped and
bringing them to within range of the
sensor and everything else is becoming a
little bit dark but it's so clean that
when you boost it later on in
post-production when you're doing color
grading you don't get very noisy results
it's still pretty clean looking so that
brings us to lighting we're talking
about a little bit dynamic range let's
talk about it more in depth here and how
to get cinematic looking shots with your
lighting the rules of lighting still
apply to cell phone footage so phones
shoot on a small sensor it means that
you don't really get shallow depth of
field that nice smooth blurry wash
behind your actors when you zoom in
right now i am in focus and the
background is out of focus and things in
the foreground are also out of focus the
goal with depth of field usually is just
to isolate your subject it tells you
what you should be looking at you know
you're not supposed to look at the
background because the background's all
blurry you're supposed to be looking at
me it also tells you that the background
is far away or my hand is close to the
camera pictures are flat they're
two-dimensional for us to get in depth
out of that picture we use things like
shallow focus movement and lighting to
separate the elements into a perceived
three-dimensional space because you're
on a cell phone and you can't make the
background out of focus and you can't
make objects in the foreground out of
focus you need to use lighting to
separate your subject from the
background and possibly the foreground
here's how you do that you can use an
edge light to put an edge light on your
subject that will go a long ways towards
separating what we're supposed to be
looking at from the wash of things that
are behind them also either make your
subject slightly brighter than the
background or make your subject slightly
darker than the background that's what
they do in house of cards they tend to
have the characters slightly darker in
the background at times
this creates contrast between you and
the background or you or your subject
whatever you're filming maybe it's you
this creates contrast between your
subject and the background and it
separates them once again because you
can't do that with focus you need to
rely on tricks like lighting to do so
carmichael will you uh lock the exposure
on my face
because i cannot see my face use your
manual exposure let's say you're filming
in a dark environment and you have a
little splash of light somebody's lit a
candle or something like that your phone
is either going to try to expose for all
the darkness causing the little splash
light to become blown out and crappy
looking
or
that's probably what's going to do
actually lots of different phones handle
exposure in different ways but the
iphone handles manual exposure like this
you touch and hold on a spot in the
screen where you want your exposure and
focus to be locked now with it locked ae
slash af lock comes up if i darken the
screen it doesn't try to expose i go to
a bright spot it doesn't try to expose
it's locked to that exposure i can
change the exposure by just dragging up
and down on the screen you will override
the phone's
automatic exposure trying to guess what
you want and use your own artistry and
sensibilities for lighting instead
this is what it looks like when you use
the ronin one cannot forget the simple
rules of composition just because you're
shooting on a phone does not mean they
do not apply interesting thoughtful
framing goes a long ways towards making
your shots look cinematic play with the
edges of your frame and the space within
instead of thinking of it as a window to
the world think of it more like a 2d
canvas and you're organizing shapes and
lines colors and forms to get
interesting compositions within your
frame
an awareness of how these real-world
three-dimensional shapes look when
composed into a 2d picture is how you
get nice framing so even though you're
on a cell phone you can still get very
nice thoughtful images that are well
composed in fact you can push a little
bit further get a little pretentious
it'll look good don't forget about your
classic framing rules for example the
rule of thirds where you put your
subject on the line that marks a third
of the frame or for example the 180
degree rule where you stay
on the same line of conversation another
example diagonal lines diagonal lines
tend to be more compelling to the eye in
straight lines they lead the eye to
points of interest for example in this
shot the edge of the roof leads your eye
to carmichael in the camera another good
rule of thumb is balance
balance means balancing out one side of
your frame with something interesting on
the other side of the frame for example
in this shot i have carmichael on the
right bounced by a tree on the left
you'll notice a lot of movies they
balance out people's faces which very
much attract your eye
with a lamp or another light source
because light sources also attract our
eyes so having a light source on one
side of the frame and a person's face on
the other creates balance
also you can use imbalance to create a
sense of uneasiness or tension or
suspension
or many other things because it's kind
of a subconscious thing
you just feel something all right so i
could just get a shot of the plant
neat or like a little more artsy with it
get something in the foreground like
this plant and then get something in the
background here like that sky and then
like i mentioned pull the highlights
down just a little bit when you focus on
getting foreground mid-ground background
in your shots because you're shooting
wide angle we'll give your scene some
depth and something interesting for eye
to bounce around on
now we're going to talk about movement
movement's very related to composition
because you're going to have a nicely
composed shot for your starting point
and you want to have a nicely composed
shot
for your ending point so movement goes a
long ways to making things look
cinematic but things always move very
smoothly so you're going to want to do
the same with your phone now your phone
it's very light it's easy to move
phones also generally have stabilizers
built in so if you want to do some
movement just by hand they can generally
look all right are you trying to tell
them to focus on something are you
telling them that something is
approaching are you trying to start on
one piece of information and then move
to reveal another piece of information
that elevates the scene movement is a
great cinematic language tool and you
should use it with your phones just by
default here i am going to be shooting
everything on hyperlapse because it
provides for very smooth steady shots
and the footage looks great and i'm
going to just slowly move around this
here
sound what is sound
i don't know but
check this out you might be wondering
why am i talking about sound in a video
about how to get cinematic shots on your
phone
well
nothing makes something feel less
cinematic than
bad
roomy
sounding sound you want things to sound
present and close and crisp and you can
have a really bad looking movie with
good sound and have it be a very
cinematic movie because it comes down to
distraction you don't want people to
realize there is somebody there shooting
the scene you want them to suspend their
disbelief and think that they're
watching some character that is somehow
magically being seen on the screen
when you expose bad sound to the
audience you expose the process of
filmmaking to the audience it pulls them
immediately out of the movie so when
you're filming on your phone you're in
luck phones have really nice microphones
i mean after all i guess they're
designed to be talked into primarily so
it's makes sense that they have good
microphones the iphone has an algorithm
that isolates human voice and boosts it
in the shot which is very very useful
other phones may or may not have the
same hardware depends on what you're
using so last thing i want to talk about
here is color grading and really making
it pop and giving it a stylistic edge
we're shooting on the red camera but the
raw footage on the red camera doesn't
look very good there's fancy tools out
there like davinci resolve and there's
simpler tools like the color grading
tools built into premiere but what i
might recommend unless you want to go in
depth and learn something like davinci
resolve which is great by the way check
out look up tables depending on what
editing program you're using you can
apply these to your footage and they
will give it a nice cool looking color
style and there's a whole variety out
there so most of the footage from the
phones you're seeing in this video is
color graded the vision colors impulse
pack first we'd apply a lookup table
that will flatten your image or convert
it into what we call log kind of like uh
what you'd get out of an alexa the
second lookup table we apply then takes
that flattened image and then stretches
it back out in different areas from
there all you need to do is basic color
correction such as messing with your
levels or your rgb curves so as you can
see here we have our iphone footage and
we have our red footage and while you
can tell they're shot on different
cameras they are very visually similar
so if you were shooting with a 60d or a
dslr of any type or even all the way
down to the smallest camera which is a
phone don't be discouraged because
there's always a way to get the best out
of every camera
[Music]
so thanks for watching guys
thanks for watching guys i hope you
learned something from this and if you
guys have any questions or things you
want us to cover more in depth leave
some comments below we read them we
actually do or you can tweet at us we
also read those the tweets we didn't
want to go super in-depth because that
can end up
uh doing things does things that's the
big thing with things do you do you know
what's the difference between a wizard
and a sorcerer
so the difference between wizards and
sorcerers wizards are bookworms and they
get all their spells from books and a
sorcerer on the other hand is totally
different the sorcerer gets his spells
and magic through like intuition which
one are you are you guys a wizard
you got to read the manual or are you a
sorcerer where you just mess with all
the buttons until one does the right
thing